this video was sponsored by skillshare
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
fan of exfoliation
exfoliants are one of the first products
you start using when you get into real
skin care they're a really good gateway
product but they can be a bit confusing
and there are lots and lots of myths
about them
so we're going to do some debunking if
you want to know more about exfoliation
i have another video that goes over the
basics and i have a free downloadable
exfoliation guide all the links are in
the description
if you like nerding out about beauty
click the subscribe and the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any videos
myth number one stronger exfoliants are
better
when you start using chemical exfoliants
it's really tempting to just go for the
strongest exfoliant you can find
10% lactic acid is only 30 cents more
than 5% lactic acid so you would be
stupid not to go for it
you're getting double the exfoliation
for basically the same price
i did the maths the problem with this
logic is that over-exfoliation is a
thing
first off chemical exfoliants are great
but a lot of them need a low pH to work
that means they're quite acidic which
probably isn't a big surprise if you've
ever looked at a chemical exfoliant
label
your skin is acidic but not quite that
acidic so the lower the pH
the stronger the product but then the
higher the chance of potential chemical
burns
now even if you have an exfoliant where
the pH is okay
it's still an exfoliant exfoliants
exfoliate
that means that they're thinning down
the stratum corneum that's the dead skin
cells on the surface of your skin this
is why exfoliating gives you that nice
smooth glow
it's getting rid of excess cells on the
surface and basically polishing down
your stratum corneum but like if you're
sanding down and polishing wood
you can go too far you still need some
dead skin cells
that layer is there for a reason and
that is to form a barrier
this barrier keeps water in so that your
skin stays hydrated
and it also keeps out irritants and
germs if you over exfoliate and you've
made this layer too thin that's where
you start running into these problems
with a compromised barrier
your skin is going to be more likely to
get tight and dehydrated
your skin is also going to get a bit
more sensitive so it might go a bit red
products that never used to sting might
sting even water might sting
you'll have more inflammation and that
leads to more breakouts it is a whole
mess
and it takes ages to resolve and you
have to just wait and baby your skin and
not use any actives for weeks
it's much better just to not do too much
in the first place to avoid
over-exfoliating unfortunately you have
to use a lot of self-control
and patience and listen to your skin
start with a lower percentage product
and slowly ramp up the strength if your
skin can take it and increase the
frequency as well if your skin can take
it
if your skin starts getting
over-exfoliated so if it starts stinging
if it looks a bit red
if it's looking a bit too tight then you
have to back off and use a weaker
product or even no product at all while
your skin recovers
that means that these low percentage
products have a place in your routine a
really important place so don't just go
for the strongest product you can
find myth number two you can't use
chemical exfoliants in the morning
this myth comes from the fact that in
some studies glycolic acid made skin
more photosensitive
so in other words made it more likely to
burn and tan alpha hydroxy acids all
work about the same way so this probably
applies to other ones like lactic acid
as well
but the way that you get this
photosensitivity isn't with the alpha
hydroxy acids reacting with sunlight
it's that they've changed the structure
of your skin so that it's more sensitive
to the sun
and then you go out into the sun with
this newly sensitive skin
it doesn't matter whether or not the
acid is still on your skin this effect
can last for over a week
after you've stopped using the exfoliant
so it doesn't matter if you use it in
the morning or night your skin is still
going to be more likely to get damaged
by the sun
so the bottom line is you can use
chemical exfoliants anytime you like
just make sure you use a sunscreen which
you should have been doing anyway
myth number three physical exfoliants
aren't good for your skin
there's this idea in some places that
physical exfoliants are the devil and
you should only use chemical exfoliants
this is just not true physical
exfoliants in the right
hands can be really effective one
example is microdermabrasion
dermatologists and skin therapists use
this to help with acne scarring
uneven skin texture and wrinkles the
issue is that some physical exfoliants
are really easy to overuse
some of them even have instructions that
say to use them way too regularly
and that scrubbing feeling is really
satisfying so people are more likely to
keep going too hard
it's like if it hurts it has to be
working and so a lot of people who are
new to skin care will use them and use
them way too regularly
and then you end up in that
over-exfoliation territory and a lot of
really strong physical exfoliants things
like harsh scrubs and cleansing brushes
these are really accessible to people
who are new to skincare and so it might
even be their first skincare product
and so when people start getting into
skincare and stop using these products
their skin improves a whole bunch and so
it looks like those products are really
bad but it doesn't mean that people who
are more experienced
can't use them safely and effectively
later on there are also a lot of really
gentle physical exfoliants out there
like konjac sponges and peeling gels
these are just a bit less well-known
there's also one really big advantage
with physical exfoliants
because they work right away you can
tell when you've exfoliated enough and
stop
it's not like a chemical exfoliant where
you wake up the next day with a really
raw face
there's also no good evidence that
physical exfoliants cause microtears
that make your skin more prone to
infections overexfoliation can do this
because it makes your skin barrier a bit
crap but this happens with chemical
exfoliants as well
myth number four people with dark skin
can't use glycolic acid exfoliants
this isn't true there are tons of
studies where glycolic acid peels were
used on people with dark skin so that's
fitzpatrick 4 or higher and these have
really good results including fading
pigment
this one used 35% glycolic acid this one
used 70%
this one used 30% glycolic acid with 20%
azelaic acid
this one specifically looked at how safe
it was to use a 50%
monthly glycolic acid peel on indian
women and they found hardly any side
effects
these studies use glycolic acid at
really high percentages in peels
and so with a lower percentage product
you'd probably have less side effects
i think where this myth comes from is
that hyperpigmentation is a side effect
of chemical peels if you use too high
strength or if you leave it on for too
long
and darker people are more prone to
hyperpigmentation that's one of the
reasons why doing a chemical peel at
home
is quite risky it's a lot safer to go to
someone who knows what they're doing and
knows how to avoid these issues
this also comes from the fact that
glycolic acid is a smaller molecule so
it can go deeper into your skin than
other alpha hydroxy acids
so if you have a glycolic acid product
or a lactic acid product and everything
else about them is the same
the glycolic acid product is probably
going to cause more side effects
but there are tons of other things in
alpha hydroxy acid products that will
change how strong they are the two main
things are the percentage and the pH
so a five percent glycolic acid product
at pH 4 is going to be less risky than a
40% lactic acid peel at pH
2. now a 40% glycolic acid peel at pH 2
might be riskier than the lactic acid
one
but as we can see from the scientific
evidence and from the dermatologists and
estheticians who use glycolic acid peels
on dark skin all the time
both can be safely used in the right
hands myth number five you can't use
chemical exfoliants and retinoids at the
same time
there's no rule that you can't use a
chemical exfoliant at the same time as a
retinoid
they won't cancel each other out or
react dangerously or anything like that
some retinoids do tend to work better at
a higher pH than chemical exfoliants
but pH isn't that much of an issue after
the product's been absorbed into your
skin
if you're still worried you can wait a
few minutes between putting them on
there is still a potential issue though
both are pretty irritating
it's possible that your skin can't
handle both without getting really
irritated and angry
and overexfoliated so it's a good idea
to start with really gentle products and
add one in at a time
and monitor your skin really really
carefully if you want to know more about
exfoliation i have a few more videos on
it
leave me a comment if there's a myth
that you'd like to see busted or if
you're not sure something's a myth if
you like this video click the thumbs up
and subscribe it really helps with the
algorithm
this video is here thanks to skillshare
i'm super grateful that they sponsor
educational channels like mine
skillshare is an online community that
has thousands of classes on a huge range
of topics
there's classes on things like design
photography video
and web development as well as the more
business side of things like marketing
freelancing and analytics for someone
who's been creating content for a really
long time
i'm still really bad at procrastinating
and getting stuff off my to-do list
i've been trying to get better at that
and one of the classes i just finished
is real productivity how to build habits
that last
by thomas frank this isn't just about
how to work more it's about how to set
realistic goals
and how to build habits that let you
progress towards your goals in a
sustainable way
and also about what to do when you feel
unmotivated and i really wish i knew
about the sorts of skills that thomas
teaches in this class
earlier if you want to check it out the
first thousand people to use the link in
the description will get a free trial of
the skillshare premium membership for a
limited time
it's less than $10 a month with an annual
subscription and there's always
interesting new classes launching
so thank you again to skillshare